Sophie M what was the casting process
for et like
actually they just offered me ET I had
auditioned for Stephen for used cars oh
I love used cars and I didn't
fortunately I know but I loved it
you see this car right here the price is
2 400.
two [__] high
slams it with a with a sledgehammer and
dude it was uh what's his name uh right
there Kurt Russell yeah oh God that
movie's hilarious I was destined to do
E.T did they pay UL an E.T yes
because I held out really long time
serious yes well it's negotiation yes
you know that's the way it goes how much
money do you think you've made in
residuals on ET from 1982 not enough
but do you still get them you still get
them yes yes and I feel blessed every
single time a check comes in
do you still talk to any of the cast
members oh gosh the boys and I are on
tour all the time are you serious we go
to the cons all the time do you think
Henry would do this I'm friends with
Mike Flanagan who's friends with him
who's he's been in a lot of his projects
I should talk to Mike or you yeah he's a
good guy talk to Mike Oh Henry Henry's
fabulous he's wonderful it says Robert
oh and so you know we did Drew an hour
show with Drew this year yeah I saw that
that was amazing that was great that she
did a really wonderful job with that
show I thought by the who's made you
laugh who is the funniest person you've
ever worked with that you you always
were like about to laugh Dom DeLuise oh
yeah my God and it was I had all these
serious scenes what movie
oh it was a movie of the week okay
called Happy
and and so I would get ready to do all
these serious things and and he'd look
at me and go
[Music]
math
and he would just go off